the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so misconceptions so misconceptions
alternative conceptions understanding
the student view of the world why is
that important well one of the best ways
to introduce the importance of the idea
is a story so this is now I'm not 100%
sure the story is true but it's so good
that it has to it ought to be true even
if it is I think it is actually true so
this was a two basically let's say
physics TAS physics grad students who
were in a philosophy class and the
teacher in the philosophy class said
well they were talking about relative
things being relative and morals being
relative and things being in general
relativity in philosophy and said well
as an example of relativity and things
being relative depending on situation if
you drop a pencil on the earth it'll
fall to the ground but if you drop the
pencil on the moon it won't fall to the
ground it'll just float and so most of
the people in the class just nodded so
know that you know yeah basically thing
you know that's a good example but the
two physicists in the class were a bit
shocked and said we'll wait a minute
wait a minute that can't be true surely
it must did something's wrong here so
they raised their hand they said well
wait a minute if you drop a pencil on
the moon surely it's going to fall to
the ground to the ground of the moon and
they you know and then there are other
people in the class said no no that's
right that's that's not right so they
thought okay well we must must have some
way of convincing them that the pencils
not going to flow and they said okay
well you all saw the pictures of the
astronauts walking on the moon right you
said oh yeah well mm did the and then
when the astronauts no walk did they
just float away or did they stay on the
moon oh they stayed on the moon well how
did that happen you know they thought oh
we have him now right and what was the
response the response was oh well that
was because the astronauts were wearing
heavy boots so so here was a chance to
do a bit of educational research so they
thought oh my god maybe this is this
just this class let's actually do a
survey so they took out the university
phone directory and just randomly dialed
people and they called him up and said
okay if you drop a pencil on the moon
will it float away or will it fall to
the ground and most of people said I was
going to float away so then they said oh
yeah but what about the astronauts and I
gave him the whole thing about the
astronauts again and about half of the
people said oh yeah that's because the
astronauts were wearing heavy boots so
again they were shocked and
flabbergasted and I think that reaction
is a very healthy reaction but it what
it shows is that the students so in this
case they weren't officially their
students but students they could easily
be your students have can have a very
different view of the world of the
physical world than you have right and
if that's true that means that as you're
teaching them what you're teaching is
actually being interpreted in this
completely different way I think he
could have said that he said you know
mathematicians or maybe was Frenchman I
was either Frenchman or mathematicians
maybe he was mathematicians they have
their own language and everything you
tell them they first translate into
their own language and only then do they
understand it so that's the same thing
the students are translating the things
you're saying into their own language
but to understand what they're
translating into you have to know what
their language is okay so in other words
you have to understand not just the
misconceptions but in
general the conceptions that students
have so that you can actually plan your
teaching and here is a diagram to
illustrate that so this is a model of
teaching to see where all the pieces fit
in so here this is the system which is
how students think this is the output
which is what students can do after we
they go through our teaching and this is
the input which is what we do what kind
of classroom structure we setup what
assignments we do and by this I mean how
students think just individually and
collectively how students work together
as well so generally speaking the way so
this is the system and call this the
result and this is the teaching our
problem is to try to figure out the
teaching
and how do you figure out the teaching
well well you start with figuring out
what results you want what do you want
students to be able to do what what's
your goal for the class and then you
have to run it back through the system
right so you you figure out the result
and you can run it through the inverse
of s and then there's your teaching that
that's the teaching equation let's call
it now those of you from engineering
fields know that basically anything the
only thing you can do anything with is
in linear systems right and
unfortunately and anything that's even
slightly nonlinear basically it's a bag
of tricks and there's nothing you can do
and you're just hosts all right well
unfortunately this system is incredibly
nonlinear so it's probably kind of hard
to work out s inverse even if you can
work out R but it's hard but it doesn't
mean you can't start and a necessary
condition for even doing anything in
this direction is you have to know what
is in s right how do students think
another necessary condition is you need
to work out R and that's actually
something then what is the result you
want so that's we're gonna talk about in
the session on course design that's
something that's often forgotten in
teaching and it's fundamentally
important that if you don't plan your
goals if you don't plan where you want
to go your chance of getting there is
pretty low okay so you episode zoom
you've done that the next thing you want
to do is you want to understand how
students think so that you can plan your
teaching to reach them in other words so
you have some chance of working out s
inverse now you can't actually write
down some equation for s inverse but you
can invert it mentally in your head and
the necessary condition for doing that
is to understand s so you want to
understand where students are coming
from so that you can work out T okay so
that's the signals and systems model of
teaching now an example again to show
the importance of doing that and what
happens if you don't actually understand
where the students are is yet another
example from freshman physics
I'll leave this here so this is one of
the examples from the readings so not
everyone may have read that reading it's
the reading by ryf and it's this problem
so this is a pendulum at five points in
its arc so this is the end points and
the question people are asked was where
it was to draw the acceleration vector
at these five locations so what's the
acceleration right here here here here
and here
so it's not I'm not so interested in
what the actual answer is and so much as
how people did on this so this is
actually really shocking
so in it of students in intro physics
who had an acceleration so they'd done
acceleration zero out of 124 students
could do that problem
so that's 0% so of grad TAS it was 20 no
it was 15% so these are grad TAS in
physics who ta that course and PhD
students so this was PhD students on
their qualifying exam
it went up to 22% okay so now this is a
you know a really I mean it's a
fundamentally important idea
acceleration but you'd expect PhD
students on their qualifying exam to be
at a hundred percent and you'd like the
TAS in the course to be at a hundred
percent because there's no chance of
them teaching the students an idea that
they themselves don't understand as
polio said there's no method of teaching
yet invented that will allow the
students to understand what their
teacher does not and that's true there's
no amount of sort of trickery with style
and things you can do to convey an
understanding that you don't have so
this is a very shocking number to me and
pardon george pólya
so so polio was a great mathematician
and mathematics teacher from Hungary and
then eventually at Stanford and he's
written I'll put his reading
I'll put references to his books on
their website but they're some of the
best books on math teaching ever written
and so he said that in one of his books
and it's I think very true so what this
example shows is that well a the
teachers didn't understand it but that
really fundamental ideas can be
completely skipped over for years and
years and years
yes lies
others what if Felix Everett darn it
okay so how the question is how
difficult is this problem it's it's an
interesting problem because it's
difficult if you try to do it by just
blasting out the equations so they
actually asked a bunch of faculty
members the same question and one of
them just got completely tangled in not
physics faculty trying to write out the
differential equation and figure out
what the acceleration is by brute force
so yeah it is hard if you do it that way
but if you actually understand well I'll
show you what the acceleration means
then it's no problem so for example here
the thing isn't moving
so it has V equals zero but what
velocities is it gonna have just a bit
later well it's gonna be going that way
so that means the acceleration is that
way yeah so they were given quite a
while I think it was when the study on
the faculty members I think it was a big
long think a lot of protocols they were
given like half an hour in fact the time
is what hurt them because they thought
oh I have so much time I'm gonna just
blast it out with equations right and if
you were only given like one minute you
might have actually had a chance cuz he
realized oh I have to think about this
intuitively and so here same thing by
symmetry and then this one is hard this
one's hard but this one right at the
center is much easier so this one
catches a lot of people but here it's
moving in a circle and it's at its
maximum speed so here it's moving its
maximum speed so it's not going to be
going faster that way or that way so its
speed is actually at a max which means
there's no change in speed so you're not
going to get any acceleration in that
direction but because it's moving in a
circle somebody's yanking it upwards
right so has to be accelerating upwards
to move in a circle because it was going
this way and then later is going that
way so it has to be going accelerating
upwards so there is an acceleration
vector upwards
like that say all these guys okay so
this is a bit exaggerated it's generally
not that big and then the question is
these guys well it's just interpolation
it's somewhere between that and that so
it's gonna be something like that and
something like that depending on where
exactly they are but this was the one
that tripped up a lot of people okay all
right and in fact a lot of people got
tripped up because they memorize the
following thing which is I a my object
and simple harmonic motion has no
acceleration at the equilibrium point
and that's true except this isn't a
simple harmonic motion it's almost but
it's a pendulum it's not a pure spring
so it has circular motion so if you
reason about it from the motion it's
actually very quick but if you try to
blast it out with equations you're
basically hosed so I wanted to check
also you know how deep are these
misconceptions so I actually did a
survey of students in Cambridge in the
physics major and so one of the
questions I asked them was the following
so I made a survey of nine questions and
I wanted to see how they reasoned
intuitively on these nine questions and
to force intuitive reasoning I only gave
a few minutes to get around the problem
so they knew that basically solving
writing out a bunch of equations wasn't
gonna help because you had no time to
actually write them all out
so this is
so the question was which is going to go
faster down the plains so this is a
these are two identical planes incline
planes with angle alpha and there's
either going to be a disc like a coin
rolling down the plane or a ring you
know like somebody's wedding ring
rolling down the plane and the question
is which goes faster or which has a
bigger acceleration so this will call
the hoop and this is the disc and
they're going down the same angle I
didn't say that the question is is the
mass the same so I'm gonna give you that
choice so the question is which goes
faster in acceleration or velocity so
the choice is in the hope so to answer
the question about mass so one of the
choices is that it depends on mass
depends on radius depends on Alpha so it
could depend on the mass the radius or
on alpha it could be the same and the
disk could be faster and the hoop could
be faster okay so just for fun and I
realize this is not a physics class but
it's fun to actually try to guess the
answer to this even if you're not a
physicist so choose ABCDE or F in
cooperation with one or two neighbors
okay and then I'll talk about my
analysis of this problem yes
okay take a take another 30 seconds and
collective vote again it doesn't really
matter whether you get it right or not I
just want you to think about it so you
realize it is not it is a subtle
question okay so who votes for the coop
being faster nobody who wrote for the
disk being faster okay about who votes
that they're the same that it depends on
the mass you'd like to know the mass
fair enough that you'd like to know the
radius that maybe 12 that you'd like to
know the incline plane angle I know we
like that one okay so this is okay so uh
and now who's sure of their answer okay
so that's a much lower number okay so
now I can show you what numbers came up
when I asked students this so this was
11% 35% 13%
this one is 11% as well
radius was 26% and 3% so kind of similar
I kind of similar to your percentages
then again only about a third of the
people were sure of their answer okay so
why is this interesting well first of
all all the students had the technical
knowledge to do the problem these are
all physics majors in various years one
through four so freshman through senior
but the freshman had seen the material
to actually do this and calculate it if
they needed to
okay so now this problem illustrates
well first of all that even an intuitive
question like this
can actually trip people up even if
they've done all the calculations okay
so the question is well water how are
they reasoning so now in Cambridge I had
the advantage of actually also doing
tutorials because that's how basically
half the teaching goes
so in tutorials I actually I set this
problem for my students and I got a
chance to talk to them about it so I got
to figure out how are they reasoning
about it so I asked them well what do
you think is gonna happen and then
please explain why more than you could
get just from multiple-choice and the
answers were very revealing what they
said was many of them said well just as
heavier objects fall faster so should
heavier objects roll faster so that was
basically to justify they wanted to know
either the radius or the mass because
that would affect the mass and now it
also affect the mass so let me put that
up again because that's a really
interesting statements
so actually what I call this this is
what I call the America it's like the
American theory of the British accent
some of you know my explanation of that
so the American theory of the British
accent is that if you go to an English
person and you step on their feet in the
middle of the night they'll actually cry
out in an American accent which is to
say that the American sort of folk
theory of the British accent is that the
British accent is a fake that people
just put on and in moments of stress
they forget to do the put on act and
okay so now why do I bring that up well
because it's very it's very similar so
if you ask the students do have yer
suppose you didn't tell them this
question about inclined planes you just
say do have your objects fall faster now
you don't know where air resistance or
anything like that they say oh no
definitely not right Galileo showed that
but what this shows is that in a new
situation in other words where they
don't have their automatic reactions all
of a sudden the folk theory comes out
again right heavier they really do think
heavier objects fall faster right so how
can you reconcile that with if you ask
them they'll say no they don't
well that's because they've had so much
experience with every time they said
that someone said what heavier objects
fall the same speed Galileo showed that
leaning tower of pisa so it becomes like
this linguistic string which doesn't it
hasn't actually been incorporated into
their way of thinking about how the
world works right they think force is
related to velocity heavier objects fall
faster and to get that to come out you
have to for example equivalent to
stepping on them in the middle of the
night and surprising them right so this
you surprise them with a completely new
context which is the rolling rolling
they haven't thought much about rolling
so all of a sudden they're now thinking
about rolling and they're not thinking
about all the policing rules that they
were told about what happens to heavier
objects and so now their true way of
looking at the world comes out which is
that heavier objects fall faster
okay so again if you don't realize that
that's what they're doing your teaching
is going to be completely pointless I
and what's going to happen is the
following
which is that here are two models this
is so there's they basically students
will develop two models of the world in
their mind one is the sort of school is
called the school model and another is
their intuitive model and let's say they
start out a bit different from each
other and now you do a whole bunch more
teaching and you don't take account of
the fact that this belongs in their
intuitive model and you teach a bunch of
stuff about rolling down the plain you
do it with a bunch of equations by the
way I should tell you what the right
answer is the right answer is this one
it actually doesn't matter how heavy
they are because it's a gravitation
problem but if suppose you just
calculate it out well what have you done
you've overlaid on top of this you've
put in so this is in their intuitive
model you've done a whole bunch of
calculations which contradict it and the
two models diverge farther and farther
from each other
so now next time they have to solve a
problem they have to decide whether I'm
going to use the school model or the
intuitive model and they learn okay well
the intuitive model doesn't work very
well let me use the school model so the
school model basically keeps diverging
and the intuitive model and the school
model never meet again okay which means
that they can't use their intuition for
solving any of their problems you give
them or that they're gonna solve later
so that is an educational tragedy so the
divergence
and in my view that is the fundamental
reason why most teaching produces no
results a year later because what you've
done is you develop the school model the
symbolic crunching whatever it may be
but you haven't actually yanked the
intuitive model and school model
together you need to actually work on
bringing them together so now a natural
question is how do you do that so let me
give you another example of a similar
misconception in a way of yanking the
two together yes question
oh yeah why why is it the disk yeah sure
so first of all why doesn't it depend on
let's say the mass so that that's one
thing that clear up right away and one
way to reason about that the sort of
maybe the best way in a physics class is
to do it by dimensions but another way
is the following thought experiment
which is suppose I have two disks let's
see I might be poor today I only have
one disk in my pocket all right well
here's two disks okay then the chalk is
also a disk so now suppose I have one
piece of chalk and I want to roll it
down the inclined plane and now I asked
about a second piece of chalk okay let's
say they're identical piece of chalk
they're both gonna go to the same speed
okay now suppose I stick a bit of glue
on this chalk in that chalk and I stick
them together they're gonna go again at
the same speed as if the glue weren't
there because the glue isn't even being
stressed they're just moving identically
so what I've shown by that experiment is
that a heavy piece of chalk moves just
the same as a light piece of chalk so
it's quite plausible from that reasoning
that math doesn't matter
why doesn't radius matter well you can
do a couple scaling arguments to show
that the torque extra torque you get
from being bigger is exactly canceled
out by the extra mass because you're
bigger so the the radius doesn't matter
mass and radius don't matter so then
it's just the question of shape which is
a dimensionless thing and what it is
intuitively is how concentrated is the
mass near the center versus near the
edge
so suppose I actually made a extreme
version of the hoop and actually I did
this for the students in Cambridge we
manufactured and you can actually
imagine what it is so here's imagine
this we're hollow inside that would be
your ring or your hoop well can you make
anything that would move even slower
because I'm cleaning the hoop moves
slower in the disk yes what you do is
you put giant ears on the thing so it
rolls like a you know those dumb Bell
things you do for weight lifting so you
it rolls on this radius but it has these
giant ears well it's just gonna move so
slowly because it's just being yanked by
this really weak force and as to
accelerate this giant mass no chance so
it moves really slow in fact that thing
it can take like 20 seconds to go down a
meter long inclined plane all right so
that's an extreme version this is so it
rolls on this and this is these big ears
so that's really slow that's medium slow
and that's faster and if you put all the
mass right at the center would be even
faster because the rolling wouldn't suck
up any of the energy okay so that's the
intuitive explanation
okay so now an example of a question
showing a kind of similar misconception
it's a related misconception but I'm
going to show it to you to illustrate
what you can do about these okay so what
can you do right so the the question is
the following
so that's a steel ball mm-hmm which I
have in my hand and I drop on a steel
table say from a meter up pie
forget about air resistance it bounces
off the steel table and the question I'm
interested in the forces on it okay so
what are the forces so here's my table
so while it's falling so I'm interested
in the forces on it at three different
points in its flight first while it's
falling you know I let it go and hasn't
yet hit but at the instant that it's
stationary during its bounce and while
it's rising okay so now when you ask the
students this and I've done this several
times mostly they know it's just gravity
while it's falling
so mg so the way if you actually use
this question don't ask that this is
chronologically next but don't ask that
next ask this one when it's rising and
what you'll find what do you think many
students say not all but many what are
the forces on it while it's rising
Yeah right some will say the force goes
up right they'll say mg up right and I
see people laughing and that's a good
reaction because that shows you're
learning something about how students
think cuz that's kind of amazing why
would they possibly say that well let's
talk about this one and you'll see that
it's actually a similar mode of
reasoning to this so what you'll find is
even students who get this correct so
this isn't right it's mg down all right
but there's a deep-seated misconception
that if something's moving upwards it
has to have a force pushing it upwards
right and then the force somehow gets
used up and then it stops okay well what
about here okay so now they all agree
that there's weight pushing down so
that's the mg and then the question is
what's the other force and and they call
it by different names in America it's
called the normal force which is a
terrible name and in England is called
the reaction force which is a terrible
name for another reason which is that it
implies that it's it's the result
somehow our reaction it's not so it's a
terrible name but let's ask the students
how big is this force okay so it's
upwards everyone agrees it's upwards but
how big are in depending on which
country you're in okay so I take a
minute or two and for yourself figure
out how big our or the reaction force of
the normal force is in comparison with
the weight okay so this is a small steel
ball dropped from say a meter and
bouncing off a steel table
so two questions first figure out what
you think and second figure out what do
you think students are gonna say okay so
you're doing both trying to get into the
student mind okay
so let's do a quick vote so what's the
ratio between that normal force and the
weight all right are they so who votes
for equal will take first we'll do what
you think and then we'll do what
students think okay so who thinks
they're equal to 2 1 greater than 10 but
not quite a thousand greater than a
thousand to one okay so okay now what do
you think students say what's how many
say one to one how many say two to one
how many say greater than ten greater
than the fo2 greater than a thousand and
how many are not sure what the students
are going to say okay so actually when
you ask the students it depends on the
population but generally what I find is
it's 90% for one one two one and about
10% for two to one and no one says
anything else okay so now why would
students say one to one
what's the reasoning going on in their
mind has no velocity right so and that
is exactly the same reasoning as this
with mg upwards but what's interesting
is even the students who know it's mg
downwards still say well the velocity is
zero so V equals zero therefore it's in
equilibrium therefore there's no forces
acting on it therefore the reaction
force or the net work force and the
weight have to cancel okay so and equals
mg because it stopped right in that what
I call that is I call that the F equals
MV theory of physics right so now maybe
I'd like a no linguistic suppose I put a
star by saying don't say that right
that's not how you translate that
sentence into real life but why F equals
mV
why is it so deep-seated well we have a
gazillion hours of experience with it
suppose I move a object and I push it
stop pushing it it stops moving right if
I have a light object all right just
push it a little less and it moves and I
stop pushing in a stops moving so I so F
is related to M and F is related to V
this seems to explain most of our world
right it's hard to get around that so
the question is how do you actually try
to force the students to see that that's
actually completely junk what they said
and that it can't be equal and the way I
want to do it is I want to do it in a
way that recombines their intuitive
model in their school model I want to
meld them together so the way I do that
is the following
which is I get a rock so let's call this
a rock and I asked one of the students
could I please borrow your hand and so
somebody gives them in their hand and I
say ok I'm gonna put the rock on your
hand now what's the weight of the rock
of mg ok great so what's the force of
the rock on your hand mg great ok now I
hold the rock about the same place I'm
gonna you know just drop the steel ball
and I say okay on the count of three I'm
gonna drop the rock on your hand
one two and then I'm ready right what
are they gonna do like that right and as
soon as they try to do that grab their
hand and say whoa wait a minute let's
reason about this with physics why are
you moving
and you just told me that when the thing
bounces yeah it's still mg the reaction
force and the normal force is still mg
and you just showed me that mg on your
hand didn't hurt your hand
right you could hold the rock on your
hand no problem so why are you moving
your hand so then we'll have a
discussion and many of the men will then
change to two to one they'll say oh well
it's actually it's two to one and I say
okay two to one well I have an answer
for that two rocks so I have two rocks
and I put them on their hand so now
compared to the first rock mg 2 mg okay
two mg great okay so now I take the
first Rock I'm gonna drop on your hand
and one two three a little and they try
to move it I know you just told me two
mg was fine right this felt fine to you
right and they said I know it's gonna
hurt like hell
so so now what they're doing is they now
have some kind of contradiction that's
evident between the school model and the
intuitive model and now is your
opportunity right to introduce and
explain yeah you're right
your intuitive model is actually correct
in this case and your school model
reasoning is incorrect
so actually what we're gonna do is try
to move the school model towards a piece
of your intuitive model that is correct
we're trying to get away from the F
equals and V part of the intuitive model
and emphasize the part that it does know
and the part that says oh yeah I don't
want to have that rock at my hand is
correct so then they're very ready to do
a school model calculation of how big
the force is and it turns out to be
something like hundred thousand or ten
thousand times the weight so it's huge
because the impact time is so short and
then to make that plausible to them you
can actually calculate the impact time
or estimated but then you can actually
say look you already know this you
intuitively understand that because if
you again I'll stand on the table
if suppose you're gonna jump off an
object like this what do you do when you
land what does everyone do bend your
knees right so you do that right and
what does that do that increases the
contact time in why are you increasing
the contact time because that decreases
the acceleration the acceleration is a
change in velocity divided by the
contact time so you increase the
continent can't effect the change in
velocity very much that's either V or -
V or something like that but the contact
time you can change so with the steel
ball the contact time is actually very
short because speed of sound is so fast
so the impact force is really high so
yes your school model your intuitive
model was correct and now we're yanking
the school model towards it so you
actually bring the two together and you
fight the divergence in K so you want to
look for examples like that whenever you
can and to summarize the lesson because
it was pointed out that I should
summarize more often which is that the
summary of the entire theme about
misconceptions is that you need to
understand that so that you can teach
properly because there's no way to
deduce this without say doing that which
we're going to talk about later but even
knowing that if you don't know this you
can't run the system backwards and
figure out what goes here and so then
how do you actually learn about this
well you've done one way you've done one
way already so let me write down two or
three ways for you
so the question is how to learn about s
the student system well one way is to
read so the readers lie in Merrifield
there's lots of research about what
particular misconceptions students have
okay and I've given you some of those
readings on the website but there's a
whole vast body of literature and many
fields have that so you can look at that
another way and this is so this is shut
your mouth now why is that well there's
no way to really understand what
students are thinking unless you ask
them and if you don't let them talk
you're not going to actually hear what
they're thinking you'll actually put
words into their mouth because you won't
imagine that they think F equals mV
right you never would imagine that so
you have to shut your mouth and listen
okay so whenever you so use office hours
as a chance for that and related to that
is the feedback sheet if students get in
the habit of asking you questions about
and what was confusing you start to
build a model of the student system of
what worked and what didn't work and
what was confusing for them so all these
ways are ways to build models of S which
is absolutely necessary for deducing T
okay any questions
okay so if you could do the two things
one is to just spend one minute filling
out the feedback sheet and the other is
everyone who has a homework equation
treatment please raise your hand okay
that's great
so now just find one person near you to
swap with question yeah okay so that's
great so just find one person who has
one near you to swap with and give each
other comments and then just write you
your name over the next week and bring
it in next time with you okay
so basically this is it a way and if you
do there's no one near you or they've
already swapped just make a group of
three it's no big deal okay
does anyone not have someone to swap
with yeah okay great and so introduce
yourself to the other person it doesn't
matter if you're in different fields it
often can be an advantage because you'll
get a fresh set of eyes on it okay
and I'll give you some directions by
email about what to look for and put it
on the website but generally just give
each other suggestions and work together
on what you thought was good and what
wasn't good and just write your name on
the person you commented on and then
you'll bring them both in you'll bring
the commented sheet from the other
person in on the next time okay or
you'll just give it back to them and
bring it this is not a big police
exercise I just want you to meet
somebody else and have practice
discussing these things and learn from
each other okay so questions about that
okay so if you could fill up finish
filling out the sheets and bring the
sheets either here or here I'll pack up
and meanwhile we'll have any questions
that people have want to talk to me
about individually outside because I
think there's another class that's going
to come streaming in with like 150
people okay so remember learn about the
student system it's probably the most
important thing to do to make your
teaching stand out and have long lasting
good effects answers from lecture 4 to
questions generated in lecture 3
so first questions from before one of
the comments well we'll say two of them
were that could we have less time for
questions but also they're very helpful
so there's always a tension there so
what I'm gonna try to do is shorten some
of the total answers of the questions
and then maybe put some answers to the
questions towards the end of the lecture
as well I do like to try to answer most
of the questions the reason being is
that it provides also pacing yeah and
you'll find that too if you find
yourself generating four times as many
questions as you have time to answer the
next time that probably means you did
way too much stuff the previous time so
it gives you a feedback signal on how
much material to discuss in the class
time okay so and so that's one reason
I'm reluctant to just put all the
answers on the web because that's sort
of like teaching with slides where you
can just flip through all the equations
really fast and it seems like you've got
through a lot of equations but actually
no one really understood the equations
all right so it's sort of a symptomatic
treatment for a more fundamental problem
which may be that I'm doing too many
things and not allowing enough time for
questions in the class itself okay so a
general question which is how do you
evaluate your own teaching when do you
feel good or bad about how class just
went and what metrics do I use
popularity covering what I set out to
how do I know all right so one major way
is I use these because I mean it's not
really that I say oh did people hate it
or like it I mean I want to know if
people hate it or liked it and I just I
don't just add up the likes and the
hates and say okay ten likes - three
hates equals seven that's great
nor batting you know 80% but I try to
get a sense of from reading the comments
what people were confused about what was
interesting to people and sort of
integrate that up and try to imagine the
whole class is one giant student mind
and then I want to know how to
I connect the material to the collective
student mind so I evaluate it that way
sort of intuitively from the comments
that people make on the sheet which is
why I hand out the sheet every time when
I think that sheet is so valuable all
right now another way it covering the
materials I set out to well I'm probably
sort of on one extreme of that which is
I don't really care how much material I
covered but let me explain why I'm on
that extreme so some people only care
about how much material is covered and
some people are more on my end so I'll
given a reason most people I would say
are on this edge so I don't need to
really justify that because you've heard
lots of reasons for that
but it's the other side all right why do
I not care well I don't care so much
just because I think class time and a
lecture course is such a small part of a
student's life
that if you haven't connected to the
students if you haven't made it click
for them got them interested made them
want to continue studying then you've
lost most of the effect of the teaching
the effect of the teaching isn't really
going to be so much in the class because
what you can do you can can't Kindle
interest Kindle a way of looking at the
world but it's really up to the students
to carry that on afterwards and if you
actually board them or they're decided
that this means whole material is
useless they're not going to do that and
then it's all just going to go away
anyway so actually what I'm much more
interested in is how much I've kindled
those interests and that's what I try to
judge using the sheets and I think
that's actually what produces the long
term change in way of thinking okay
another comment was that the rock
experiment rot which I thought was a
good pun right if you're not willing to
write out detailed derivations on the
board is it more important to have more
detailed published lecture notes and
yeah I think that's right
in fact you know that's generally
necessary but it doesn't have to be your
own published notes it could just be a
book you refer people to so we've sort
of gone backwards from Gutenberg
you know with in the days before
Gutenberg everyone read out their notes
right that was what monasteries did you
read out the Bible and at the end of you
know a year or two of doing that you had
50 Bibles because everyone took notes on
what you read that was the old
photocopier back in say the Year 1300
and then when Gutenberg came along all
the universities then did the same thing
that's what universities were basically
it grew out of the monasteries but then
Gutenberg came along and said oh
actually books are cheap now well much
cheaper than before books used to cost
roughly say five thousand dollars a book
in today's dollars but then with
Gutenberg and automatic printing they
can be much cheaper so you can and you
know we've developed printing technology
much farther so actually for a while
till word processing came along and
typesetting on your computer people
would actually just refer people to
books and say okay your student you're
expected to read these books but now
that people can make their own notes
people sort of forgot how to tell people
to use books and instead people the
lectures that just tend to write their
own notes out and the students actually
seemed for some crazy reason well
basically because of lecturers do it
I expect notes specifically for that
topic and don't want to read books so if
it gets really strange you're getting
these bizarre cycles where you'll make
notes and as long as you have notes that
seem like they're key to the lecture
that's great students will read them and
then you assemble all the notes for the
very same lectures into a book and now
suppose the book gets published the
students will say well now we want notes
again you can't say use that you know
there's the book which was the notes
because it's not specifically targeted
so part of the cure for that is reading
memos or in any way of teaching students
to do reading is to shift back to taking
advantage of Gutenberg and then once we
take advantage of Gutenberg we can worry
about taking advantage of all the web
technology and word processing
technology that we have but yeah it is
important to answer the question
directly to have the details somewhere
for the students and the best place
generally is in printed material whether
in a book or something you write
because writing it on the board it's a
very noisy by which I mean that it's
very easy to miss copy it's easy for you
to miss mistake make mistakes it's
easier for the student to make mistakes
when they're taking notes it's best to
have it all in print and also it's best
to put the high level stuff in lecture
and have all the details with in with
the students in their own comfortable
space when they have time to go back and
forth ok so then there were several
questions about how do you meld the
intuitive model and the school model are
there general principles so I talked
about how for example with the rock
example that the school model is that
when the rock isn't moving the force is
zero because it's in equilibrium so
there's no the net force is zero so the
reaction force equals the weight okay so
that's the school model the intuitive
model somewhere in there there is an
intuitive model that you don't want the
rock to fall on your hand so how do you
generate what's the general ideas behind
melding those two models so that
demonstration I showed of borrowing
someone's hand and dropping the rock on
it well not quite dropping a rock on it
but threatening to is one way but what
are the general principles behind that
so the general principles are that you
want to connect to where all the mental
hardware is alright so generally
symbolic processing it's sort of it's
it's a sort of surface phenomena on the
brain right it's about its linguistic
it's only about a hundred thousand years
old whereas perceptual reasoning so
visual reasoning visceral reasoning
those are hundreds of millions of years
old organism and doing seeing things for
hundreds of millions of years so there's
a huge difference in the amount of
hardware that we have
so symbolic hardware say is evolved for
ten to the five years and perceptual
rough rough estimates ten to the five
versus ten to the eight years so there's
about a thousand times more evolutionary
help for these things so if you want to
meld and this is basically where this is
where the intuitive model the internal
model lives so if you want to change it
you have to connect to where the model
lips you have to do things that are
perceptual so visual arguments visceral
arguments auditory demonstrations things
that create conflict somehow some kind
of conflict is also another general
principle where you expose some kind of
obvious contradiction and that's autumn
that's so beneficial because that's self
teaching as long as there's a
contradiction the students know that the
problem isn't done so in the Iraq
example there's a contradiction between
I don't want the rock dropping my on my
hand on the one hand that's the
perceptual view with the symbolic one
which is Oh net force is zero so the
reaction force equals mg so there's a
contradiction as long as you can't get
the same answer by two different ways
you know you still have more to learn
so it's self teaching you don't have to
wait for the teacher to say oh wait a
minute that's not the right answer you
know on your own so know on your own you
internally feel that there's something
wrong
so you're tapping in I would say purse
contradictions and puzzles they're
somewhat symbolic but they're also
they're kind of visceral you feel them
like oh my god that can't be right
so if you can tap into that as well
that's another way of trying to meld the
models okay that's a it's interesting I
think it's a fundamentally important
point about teaching the these two
models and I never seen it discussed
anywhere so you're the sort of first
people to hear it officially as far as I
can tell so any questions actually about
that model just because I think it is so
important
yes
but if you're in a field that tends to
be small but I was living as one nice
yeah could you so the question was what
happens if you're in a field that
doesn't lend itself to a perceptual
reasoning so well yeah there's yeah
there's visual and everything and I
think I don't like it's hard to imagine
a field that doesn't have it I'm can you
give an example right that's true so
yeah so so computer computers and
programming was in it and computer
science was offered as an example yeah I
agree with you some fields are harder
and what makes computer science harder
is that I mean computers are symbol
processing devices so it pushes them
over here but even there I think you can
do stuff like for example let's see what
could you do it well there are some
things like for example loop invariants
and you can actually turn those into
perceptions so once you have the AI once
you you get a way of looking at programs
you say oh that can't be right because
it has it has a fencepost error or oh it
keeps keeps decrementing the counter but
there's nothing to stop it from having a
floor so you start to see problems like
that and you have tools to actually like
different kind of magnifying glasses to
look at programs so you can actually
shift it that way and really good
programmers actually do look at programs
perceptually I mean
yeah so you want to encourage that and
in its true part I would say the the
field itself pushes things towards
symbolic just because it is a symbol
manipulation device so that's what makes
computer so much better at what they do
compared to humans that's why we use
computers because we're so bad at symbol
manipulation and computers are so good
at it right so our ways of solving
problems are going to be very different
than computers but the problem that we
have when we're using computers we have
to solve with human Hardware right so
when the computer isn't doing what we
want we have to try to find some way of
understanding what's going on and it
can't be just purely symbolic because
we're bad at that so you can't a medium
desperation sometimes you'll trace
through every step of a program and see
what went wrong but generally that just
overflows you with tons of data it's
much better to actually try to take a
step back break the program at the parts
you know see big chunks and make sure
the big chunks work and so you can and
experts do that not sort of
automatically because they've been
trained as experts so what you want and
in any field the experts see differently
than the novices because their
perception is different so yeah when
you're teaching computer science to
students you want to teach them ways
that are perceptual you want to teach
them visceral feelings like some one way
to do that for example is running time
of algorithms like it different sorting
algorithms take different times so
opposed you have for all the non CS
people a huge area of study in CS is
sorting suppose you have a giant list of
numbers or list of words you want to
alphabetize them all right you know text
indexing uses it all kinds of stuff uses
sorting so how fast can you sort well
they're naive sort of simplest thing to
program is called bubble sort
and that takes if you have n numbers
that take something times N squared some
flip operations so time is of order N
squared but then there's there's merge
sort which is a divide and conquer
algorithm which takes n log in now you
could just say that but it's also very
helpful for students to have a feel
because generally students don't have an
understanding of functions is what I
found they don't have a good feel for
what functions do and mean all right so
what's the definitely N squared n log n
well one way is to actually program a
sort algorithm and then try it okay
when try both algorithms and make your
list bigger and bigger when do you get
fed up right waiting for the damn thing
to finish right so that's a visceral
feeling and so n actually that will tell
you that there's a huge difference
between n log N and N squared because
this guy basically when n is around a
thousand or mocchi now with computers
are much faster let's say 10,000 you're
burning much really fed up with that
because that's a hundred million sort
operations it's gonna take mountain oh
five or ten seconds maybe it's maybe
even a bit longer if it's written in a
higher-level language so maybe you're
fed up around N equals 10,000 here
10,000 times log n well the log of
anything is never bigger than 10 as a
rough rule of thumb the reason being
that if the log of the thing we're
bigger than 10 then and itself will be
so big your computer couldn't even fit
it fit it so you're not even dealing
with numbers whose logs is bigger than
10 it depends on the base but roughly
speaking in base 10 logarithm it's never
gonna be bigger than 10 so this is say
it memos 10 and so you're you have a
10,000 only times a 10 here whereas here
you of 10,000 times 10,000 here you can
go up easily to a million before you get
fed up right and so you'll actually have
it so that fed up is a connection to a
visceral reasoning and it actually then
makes the difference between these
really really apparent so there's ways
you can do it even there
right so if you so the comment was that
if you really understand something you
can make a really compact pictorial
representation that's generally true and
that's why it takes really long time to
make those so when you're making talks
for example when we'll talk about this
later in the term and when you're making
talks and slides a really good model for
making slides is here's a slide you know
this is the four to three ratio sort of
so here is a sentence so this is some
assertion some message you want to get
across and here is the evidence the body
of the slide is the evidence and that's
a picture
generally the best is to have some kind
of visual evidence but what you find
when you do this and it is I think the
best way to make slides it takes a long
time to really find the best picture and
even to find a good picture because it's
just so tempting to write a bunch of
words out but actually if you look for
that picture you really try to capture
the main idea in a picture you will be
much more successful at conveying the
messages that you want to convey
so in general try to talk to the
perceptual system now there was a
question related to that which is that
maybe I'm too harsh or too negative
about the symbolic ways of doing things
and the particular example was well even
if I so if you remember last time I gave
this example
so this is a pendulum at this is the
extreme of the pendulum motion and the
question was what is the acceleration
vector at these various points in the
motion and I said well you know the way
to do it is the reason intuitively about
it figure out what it is here and here
understand what acceleration is and then
do this one by interpolation all right
and the comment was well yeah but you
can't even if you can't do that you can
still use the Lagrangian yeah I you know
you if I know the Lagrangian for the
system which for the non physicists is a
sort of the elephant gun you can solve
pretty much anything with the Lagrangian
so you can solve it with the Lagrangian
work out the forces everywhere and
that's true but I still maintain that
it's better to have I'm not saying it's
bad to have a Lagrangian analysis the
more ways of doing things is better but
there's a fundamentally important reason
why it's important to have the intuitive
way of doing it and that is a search
argument okay so what's the certain so
if you remember from before we talked
about chunking and how you want to have
the experts have big chunks and the
novices that small chunks okay well that
has we looked at the effect of that on
perception which is that the one of the
proxies for it was the chess masters
could remember hole positions and the
novices couldn't because they're chunks
were too small and they could and if you
remember only seven chunks which is
typical you can't remember a whole
position whereas the chess masters
chunks are like three four or five
pieces and they can easily fit a whole
position in seven chunks well there's
another perhaps even more fundamental
consequence of the different chunk size
and that is the exponential explosion in
search space so suppose
you're you're here this is your state
now and you're looking for a solution to
the problem you can't so expose the
solutions here but you don't know that
yet you're looking for the solution now
if your chunk size is really big well
let's say suppose your chunk size really
big you'll try a few possible chunks
okay none uh do any of those get me
closer well this one looks a bit likely
let me try expanding that one maybe that
one okay try this one okay and then
eventually you get your way over here so
here there's say suppose there's say
four chunks four possible approaches you
could try and there's because the chunks
are big there's only three levels so
this gives you four to the three items
to search okay now suppose you make your
chunks really really small
suppose your chunks are only half the
size so you now and every half branch
you have to search for possibilities so
this is the large chunk
so here we had one two three levels here
we're gonna have six levels in other
words four to the six possibilities to
search right so be different something
to show up in simple problems because
you may have only one level to go
through versus two levels to go through
and either method works but when you're
trying to solve interesting new problems
you want your chunks to be as large as
possible so that your search space
collapses to something manageable okay
so that's why you want to know you so
you don't want to have to reason with
the Lagrangian as the default mode it's
fine for that particular problem but if
that problem is embedded in a bigger
problem you want to just know what the
answer is gonna be roughly so that you
can continue making progress in deciding
should I go this route or this route so
that's why I'm not negative on the
standard ways but I think the standard
ways are actually generally bad for
problem-solving in new domains and you
want to augment your perception so that
you guide your search in the right
direction with big chunks okay so that's
I think fundamentally important okay so
I think that that was sort of the main
themes and the questions and I'll look
over them and see which ones they answer
probably at the beginning of next time
I'll try to leave more time for
questions today so we don't generate so
many questions next time to overflow it
okay so before I continue any questions
about these general principles of
thinking about your teaching
yes on the other so how do you encourage
the students to do the symbolic reason
because it is important and I agree it
is important just pure perception isn't
quite enough I I think you know most
courses I would say and most teaching is
sort of 99% symbolic and 1% perceptual
and it depends on the field but a rough
say estimate is I think it should be say
something like 20% symbolic and maybe
80% perceptual initially and then as you
go to more and more advanced levels if
you've done it mostly perceptual earlier
on and you develop the intuition then
you can increase the amount of symbolic
so I think the way you do it is you
build it into the structure of the
curriculum so one particular course
might just have one mix and the more
advanced students assuming they got the
perceptual material earlier are now
ready for the symbolic so there's
actually a sort of grass Nick I show for
this
so this is so that's the fraction of
symbolic
and that's the fraction of perceptual
material as you serve go on in the major
so I think this is the ideal structure
for a major because this is going beyond
course design to whole design of a major
in the curriculum all right so early on
say for the freshman it should be mostly
perceptual and there's many reasons for
that first of all they're symbolic
capacities you know we're all bad at
symbolic capacities to start with but
and as freshmen they're worse than the
seniors they haven't had time for
example to get sophisticated
understanding of differential equations
you know their algebra is rusty it's not
really practiced much so don't rely on
those modes of learning rely on the
perceptual modes and the perceptual
modes give you the big chunks and so
then once you have the big chunks well
sure that you men you're there ready for
the symbolic more and more because the
symbolic fits into the big chunks and
helps guide the search it helps actually
do the search okay I have to calculate
this then I can calculate this well each
calculation to do we need symbolic so by
the time they're graduate students
hopefully the perceptual stuff they've
had it up here it's really solid and now
they're ready you know for partial
differential equations and things like
that but earlier on you don't want to
try to avoid partial differential
equations you want to solve them in
intuitive ways and an example of that is
you know early on when you're doing
fluid mechanics you would solve the
cones using dimensional analysis as we
did before you wouldn't solve the
navier-stokes equations and later on for
example in a graduate class on
computational fluid mechanics you just
actually try to simulate that and figure
out what the drag coefficient is and
numerically you know so that's the mix
between perception and symbolic that I
think I would is a very good way to
construct a whole curriculum does that
answer your question
okay